let's piss off youtube and talk about
guns uh-oh
joe biden says uh fox news reports biden
repeats debunked second amendment cannon
claim says no amendment is absolute
this guy i look i think joe biden is
demented yeah i think he's just
generally not there true in a nunna shop
at the pressure if you know what i mean
better calf care he he he says gibberish
he's got harry
[Applause]
sit on my lap they're on my leg
from the washington post where democracy
dies in darkness
biden's false claim the second amendment
bans cannon ownership ladies and
gentlemen
not only could you actually buy cannons
back then when they drafted the
constitution and he was there
right you can buy cannons right now
it's it's like
joe biden just makes this stuff up i
honestly believe he knows he's lying but
he says this because he's trying to
change the cultural perspective of
americans he wants americans to go
around saying lies it's really annoying
when i have these lefty people i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry left i shouldn't say
lefty people because the left likes guns
the liberal establishment democrat types
i can't stand it when they're like calm
down no one's trying to take your guns
away and i was like my bear my barrett
m82 is banned in this state this state
this date and then they go well but why
would you need that hey don't change
don't let the goal post my flamethrower
is banned in maryland i want to have my
flamethrower here i can't waco
yes yeah yes not trying to take our guns
joe biden is a liar yes and you take a
look at what's going on the truckers who
mentioned this last night
the military is concerned about going in
and rounding people up because they
might be armed not so so you don't need
guns to engage in active conflict it
prevents active conflict it is a force
balancer joe biden wants to crack down
and take people's guns as they always
this is biden's doj plan and gun crime
prioritize gun violence crackdown on
trafficking
national ghost gun enforcement
initiative pursue gun sellers of illegal
guns 500 million reducing gun crime yo
they've been they they tried several
years ago banning all semi-automatic
weapons yep they put the proposed insane
because no one knows what semi-automatic
means that's the problem there's people
who don't have guns don't know what
semi-automatically the the liberal they
they do this all the time and i think a
lot of it's on purpose they'll take a
picture of a rifle and call it an
automatic weapon yes
it's a slight it's a verbal sleight of
hand yep because they can say oh well
like i meant semi-automatic which is a
type of automatic it's like come on you
know what you're doing yo it's just like
with the joe rogan thing they don't know
what they're talking about they don't
care what they're talking about they
just want a virtue signal and there's a
very serious problem
i i said it before i'll say it again
michael malus likes to say how could you
possibly be blackpilled when you see how
stupid these people are and i'm just
like yo
a zombie is stupid but a thousand of
them are formidable and can take over a
city and then convert people into
zombies and all that stuff so when i see
hordes of people on twitter who have no
idea what they're talking about
covington kids
you want to know what worries me
the covington kid incident shows how a
large group of npcs can destroy the life
of of teenagers
and
could what could be done now we
effectively countered that exactly prove
the lies but it doesn't always happen
that way look at russiagate
no i mean you're right we don't always
win but i think people are starting to
wake up to it and there are reasons to
be white pilled and their stupidity is
one of those reasons i remember when i
was looking at the footage of nick
sandman a couple years ago you had the
black hebrew israelites there and the
way the media reported on it was that
they were young african-american men
preaching about the bible and oppression
which is a hilarious way of
characterizing that if you have any idea
what the black people write yeah these
are things that would get your channel
banned if i said them out loud
but
you were also talking a little bit
earlier about the fact that
lefties really do like gun crime uh or
i'm sorry i don't don't like gun crime
they actually don't have a problem with
guns
and it's true and you sort of mentioned
establishment liberal types tend to be
more likely to be in favor of gun
control but one thing i found is a lot
of the more like milk toast
establishment democrat liberals i know
say that the one conservative position
they have is that they're against gun
control it is a losing issue for the
left overall and i think there's a white
pill there as well i just want to
mention as a as an absolute aside to
derail yeah that's part of the reason i
just want to say part of the reason i
got tripped up verbally there is because
tim was like standing messing with
things on the table luke very roykowski
look broke yep our fouchy bobblehead i
was reading
i tried to stop him he wanted to put the
gorilla on top of that yes i was
redecorating and then we were working on
on a thumb for the vlog where the
gorilla was with fouchy with with
seamus's face
motion action that was happening for the
for the luke
you are literally considering your
credibility
as a journalist
how do we get the rights to that song by
celine dion i just [ __ ] fell off
for everyone
the glasses fell off the feet were
disconnected
it was childish it was ridiculous i
tried to put a stop to it anyone who
watches the vlog is going to know that
luke is lying you've just undermined
your credibility
your career's over anyway yeah
we were talking about specifically how
when governments disarm citizens
historically this usually leads to a lot
of atrocities always does always
do this for me also that's what i'm
saying democrats even establishment
democrats the actual constituents are
generally against gun control right
right right so let me let me ask the
audience a question i'd like to ask the
audience oh can you name a country for
me where they enacted extreme gun
control measures and then people didn't
lose their rights right afterwards or
like that you know or there wasn't a
massacre or downside no no no no i mean
australia has not they're they've lost
their rights i don't know you know right
right so here's the issue the issue
might be that we're all just losing our
rights anyway regardless of whether or
not they took our guns but oh but this
is the thing so you're absolutely
correct that if people stand by their
rights are taken away but when you look
at for example the freedom convoy and
the fact that the police were too afraid
to do anything about it because they
thought those truckers might be armed it
goes to show that when people do stand
for themselves even if they as an
individual don't have a gun the idea
that they could have a gun is enough to
stop the government from cracking
and this idea of personal responsibility
of firearms is it's a it's an idea
that's becoming more popular even
amongst the left especially when we look
at it from a state by state issues the
the people's ability to be able to
defend themselves is dramatically going
up on a state level because people are
realizing hey the government is
absolutely not working in the benefit of
the general public when there's a
pandemic they're they're firing hospital
workers when there's a supply chain
crisis they're limiting the amount of
trucks that could go through the border
when there's a financial crisis they're
spending more money when there's a
potential war they're firing members of
the military for for not following their
vax mandates they're doing the exact
opposite of what they should be doing
they do not care about you and the only
person responsible for you yourself as
an individual
is yourself and no one else and people
realize that more than ever because the
the lie and the mystery of government is
being unraveled right in front of them
and people are saying hey i got to be
dependent on myself and no one else i'm
hearing this this impassioned plea from
luke very seriously standing on the
soapbox demanding that people stand up
for their rights and it's very difficult
to take seriously because of his shirt
yeah the real island
hey you got to call these players out
because these are big players that are
pushing these agendas that are trying to
america trying to turn america into
communist china where the people are
disarmed they disarmed people in
communist china and then what happened
well this this is a shirt it's a classy
elegant shirt that you should wear at
very fancy uh events uh proper attire
and it's a nice photo of of bill gates
and mr epstein uh you know depicted as
the real island boys on jeffrey
epstein's uh it's a little scene
partying and having fun staring at this
while luke is like you must preserve
your rights and stand up
i know it's ridiculous you know it's not
ridiculous it's a very serious shirt
that should bring attention to the very
close bromance that bill gates had with
jeffrey epstein that was far more
extensive which which with their common
thread of population control that they
they loved and shared and uh you know
there's a reason the corporate media
doesn't want to talk about this
gates told us epstein was giving
marriage advice right i don't know about
that no no no i don't think he said that
right
i think
he died and he was dead and there's no
reason to talk about i will say this
that was crazy he was awesome
he was like what does it matter he's
dead
they're like so what do you think about
how did he feel about it you saw he died
a relationship with him looking back and
he's like well you know he's dead
oh my god
you're absolutely right on the nail on
the head hold on hold on so as well hey
i was correct now to be fair this is uh
the daily beast but headline jeffrey
epstein gave bill gates advice on how to
end his quote toxic marriage
who's the source on that this is i mean
it's the daily beast you're going to
question exactly
i don't trust the deal hold on hey new
york post
yeah exactly new york post yeah luke is
just going to disagree with everything i
said he's going to go i don't trust that
source then he's going to be like i went
to like
conspiracy.blogspot.net and i heard that
bill gates and jeffrey upstairs a lot
more credible than the corporate media
tv legit because i keep seeing like new
media new news pops up on it and it's
like is this as far as like well yeah
just as far as i can tell they're good
so i i follow disclose.tv on twitter
they're just an aggregator oh yes
and and it's so whenever i see them
tweet something i always verify anybody
tweet something i'll see it i'll try and
verify sources i try and find what the
root source of it is disclose tends to
just be aggregating legitimate news
sources all right yeah good so you're
saying that the new york post reported
that
bill gates asked epstein for marriage
advice yeah
that he gave him uh advice on his quote
toxic marriage
i don't know why that's so funny to me
that like either of them would refer to
marriage and these like well it was it
was allegedly because of his
relationship with epstein why uh bill
gates's wife divorced him because it was
coming to light and because he refused
to stop hanging out with jeffrey epstein
dude bill gates's wife was like you know
like i don't think it i think it's a
little weird that this guy has this
island and that seems like she's toxic
bro
you have to get away from her toxic
femininity
she's a toxic woman you got to stay with
i'm your only friend bill that's right a
girl like elaine man she'll follow you
anywhere
oh man it's like i wish i had there's a
shirt
which one find a woman
that loves you the way gillane loved
jeffrey and followed them all
we have delaine maxwell did not uh you
know off herself shirt as well what's up
that one's ahead of its time did she get
convicted because i stopped following
the court case yes and we're waiting for
sentencing and we're going to just see
what's going to happen but they're also
calling for a mistrial because there's a
retrial yeah yeah because because
they're saying one of the jurors was was
tempered uh tampered with and had
previous uh instances of also being uh
hurt as a child uh and therefore it
implicated the case here but
it's amazing that they've they've not
implicated any of the uh people who are
that were part of the trafficking you
know what i mean yeah like it's like
they ran an illicit business with really
horrible things okay who was buying and
purchasing all those horrible listings
of everyone who went there and did
anything illegal if only he had been
filming that stuff and then after the
only there was a sale to find the
footage if only they were crazy safe
with with fbi labels on them already you
know
if only that would happen can you
imagine what a crazy there's more
i just want to point out to everybody
that uh this show gets between its clips
and like the live show like like almost
a million and a half two million and
we're sitting here talking about bill
gates and epstein i absolutely love it
we're winning i've been
absolutely winning we've got to get
tired of winning we're winning so much
the people who are hearing this every
day all day every day
of course they're trying to censor us of
course they're trying to censor
everybody else you know they've gone
really hard against steven crowder
they're obviously going aft after joe
rogan but i'm just sitting here listen
to luke's wearing a shirt with bill
gates and epstein on it and we're
broadcasting this out to like 50 000
concurrent people you know we'll get
like half a million in total on the
episode you're trying to get banned
right now it's like
i mean i'm messing with you but i'm just
saying even if it was just right now i'm
like we stood atop that hill and held up
that picture for all of these people to
see you're right yeah we are the
narrative is shattering their control is
shattering the people are winning i just
just feels good you know but it's like
it's like dipping our toes into hot lava
like seeing all this stuff is like now
we finally see the hot lava let's find
out oh that's that's too hot i'm not
jumping in
i don't want to know who was at
epstein's island necessarily i do i do
but i don't want to get killed in my
sleep so i don't want to talk about
it's hot lava let's figure out another
way to investigate the life hold on let
me ask you something if there was
anything worth getting killed in your
sleep for example like the way
being challenging and going up against
the biggest evils being worthwhile and
and making something extremely
challenging for yourself is a great
point that you bring up here because
we're going at the tip of the spear
we're going after some of the most
powerful most sinister most horrible
individuals on the face of this earth
who do unspeakable things we only know a
shred of of what actually is behind this
whole freaking system that is riddled
with so many people getting hurt so many
children being hurt in unspeakable ways
there's so many monsters out there and
if there's anything you should dedicate
your life to in this existence is to
fighting those monsters and protecting
the innocent and this is important work
that needs to be done and i thank you
guys for giving me the opportunity to
even speak about some of these issues it
is because
we recognize the risks in speaking out
about these things and accept them and
speak about them anyway that we're
winning it's because
joe rogan stands in the face of these
people trying to cancel him and says i'm
gonna have these conversations these
guys are credentialed they're they're
well respected i just want to have these
conversations he tries to be polite
about it but they're if we if we're the
kind of people that were like well we
shouldn't bring up some of the darkest
and most dangerous subjects now i'll be
completely honest with you guys their
censorship
we we have to navigate this minefield
same as anybody else
so we use rumble so we set up at
timcast.com so we put episodes that get
a little spicy on rumble to make sure
the conversations will persist it's not
a perfect scenario we are in a conflict
over our right to speak our minds but we
are actively navigating that that
landscape to make sure we do this was
not possible several decades ago we can
come on youtube when we when we get
issues on youtube we put them up on
rumble and our episode with darren
beatty is our biggest podcast ever with
like 2.4 million views
because when they come after us we put
it up and even more people get to see it
they can try and censor us but we are
not backing down we recognize you know
we're like i said navigating a minefield
but we're going to keep pushing and
making sure the conversations happen in
an intelligent way with alternatives and
backups where they can't get us and they
can't screw us over and even when they
do when they attack us they only prop us
up joe rogan's viewership is
dramatically increasing right now more
than it ever probably has before with so
many governments with so many
corporations attacking him trying to
silence him they only strengthen his
voice and everyone else with the ability
of the opportunities we have in front of
us right now to change the world for the
better i i i'd be willing to bet
joe's probably been hit up more to go on
his show now than ever before oh yeah
absolutely from everybody because
they're like this is the platform but i
mean he's like he's hosting robert
malone and the people who are in the
know know and they're interested now
with all this craziness you've probably
got some pr gandhi's like you got to get
some controversy going on joe rogan's
show it's going to be big buzz and then
they're going to make a big stink about
it and then you're going to be them look
at robert malone is a household name now
because of this story peter mccullough
as well also a mainline doctor that has
the credentials he's not a que he's not
a crazy person he's not a conspiracy
theorist these are medical professionals
bringing forward data and information
for americans to consume and to
critically think about and the
establishment is losing their ish over
it they're becoming so desperate they're
becoming so pathetic because of data and
information and people realizing that
they have been conned i want you to for
all of you who have seen the movie the
patriot with mel gibson
just remember that scene
when everyone when the line breaks and
they all start retreating but then mel
gibson grabs the american flag and says
oh the line and he just runs the other
direction and then all the the
revolutionary soldiers turn around and
run with them and
that's what it feels like
the mainstream media imploding the
ratings in the gutter there was a time
where i i was pessimistic now i'm
watching cnn just literally erupt in
scandals where cuomo is outing zucker
and he's losing his job and it's
implicating democrats and i'm sitting
back with my feet up laughing
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you